[Music]
I just love him so much and I'm just so
proud of how hard he's working Victoria
Beckham is one seriously proud mama for
18 year old son Brooklyn recently
started college and his career as a
photographer and we saw the Instagram of
you getting a little emotional with him
heading off to college are you okay I'm
still not okay but am I ever gonna be
okay on Sunday Brooklyn set front row at
his mom's runway show during New York
Fashion Week
I learned some things today about new
trends that I'd never seen before
you have brought new things to the
fashion world first of all the clutch
pocket its iconic and I just thought for
the first time the clutch pocket and
that's the first time I've heard it
called that and I love it it's got a
ring to it
thank you the clutch pocket where did
you come up with this you know I just
think it's fun you know fashion should
be fun and it's about finding new ways
of wearing things and they're great bags
and I just thought oh let's just put it
in a pocket of a tailored jacket and you
know a little bit of sparkle didn't hurt
anybody no girls you want to celebrate
being girls yes you really do aim to
empower why is that your manifesto why
is that so important to you you know it
started out with girl power reaching
women and girls with girls then through
music and now I can do that through
beauty I can do that through fashion I'm
a girl's girl
I really love women I've learned so much
from being on the red carpet doing photo
shoots learnt so many tricks whether
that's dressing or makeup that I want to
share with other women you know if I can
take what I've learned and share that
then that's great Victoria opened up to
et about her first-born and how much his
support means to her you know with such
a strong family and a very very close
family and we like to support each other
I'm proud of Brooklyn he's a really good
kind honest person
super super polite no one has any
anything bad to say about Brooklyn he's
friendly
he's just a really good person and it's
great to have his support and David for
more from Victoria including a look at
her latest fashion collection and what
her husband David's support means to her
tune into ET on Monday
[Music]